[Music]
humans
are rational animals also many would
have believe
yet during the pandemic decisions by
individuals institutions and governments
are rarely driven by the date for do you
know the relative risk of taking a
vaccine or not taking it
or will you just wait to see what others
experts
and celebrities do are you aware that
the risk of
dying from alcohol and tobacco-related
diseases in 2020
some 8.5 million people last year
was actually five times the risk of
dying from covert 19
which only racked up only racked up 1.6
million deaths so do
we all need to wise up and get more
rational about our decisions
and the risks we do or don't face or are
humans evolved to make social
and emotional decisions relying on the
value and importance of crowd responses
and more fundamentally which is the best
strategy for survival
emotion or reason and tonight we're very
lucky to be joined by three wonderful
speakers
who i will introduce you now um first up
we have
paul bloom who is the brooks and suzanne
reagan professor
of psychology and cognitive science at
yale university
he's known for his research on how
humans learn to understand the world
he's authored five books including his
newest book against
empathy the case for rational compassion
published in 2016.
next up we have patty costcova
who is a professor in digital health and
the director of the ucl institute for
risk and disaster reduction center
for digital public health in emergencies
which is quite a mouthful
and during the covert 19 crisis patty
has been working with and advising the
who
on digital strategy while working with
her team on a gamified app
to monitor compliance with stay-at-home
policies
and last but absolutely by no means
least we have dan ariely who is the
james b
duke professor of psychology and
behavioral economics at duke university
who is known for writing on
irrationality his books include three
new york times bestsellers
predictably irrational the upside of
irrationality
and the honest truth about dishonesty
so without any further ado um i'd like
to proceed
uh inviting you all to basically giving
me your three minute pictures on the
following
subject right so paul do we
need to wise up and get more rational
about our decisions
thank you um my friend dan ariely as you
said
writes bestsellers with the word
irrationality in a title
and he makes the point over and over
again that we're often bad at being
rational
and i think he's exactly right i think
in fact at some level he has to be right
we're animals we're not angels and our
brains have evolved for a world very
different from this point
and so when our stone age minds get
confronted of a global pandemic effect
from billions of people
we can do poorly so as one example we're
really bad at risk assessment
we use a heuristic where the salience of
an event is a cue
to how probable it is and so we
radically overestimate odds of low
frequency events like mass shootings and
shark attacks
and radically underestimate the
probability of highly frequent but more
mundane events like heart attacks or
strokes or
deaths by alcohol as another example
this is what a part of what i wrote my
book about
our moral decisions are strongly biased
by emotions sometimes leading us astray
so there's all sorts of laboratory
studies showing that we don't like to
deal with trade-offs
when it comes to being good to helping
others and we actually distrust people
who make such trade-offs
and this is a serious problem
particularly now given that any
intelligence approach to
lockdown school closures quarantines
vaccination
has to involve a complex balance between
costs and benefit
so if the question is do we need to wise
up and get more rational at our decision
the answer is absolutely at the same
time
i think we overstate how stupid we are i
think we're a lot more rational we give
ourselves credit for
and i'll make three quick points about
this first
2020 has been an enormous success story
for the paradigmatic example of human
rationality
which is the practice of science if
there are still any skeptics in the
world
about whether science captures truths
about objective reality
i'd be quite happy if you'd handed me
over your vaccine when it's your turn to
get it because i personally am very low
down the queue
second we have goals other than truth so
in the middle of the summer last year in
the united states there were large
rallies for donald trump
and many people including many
epidemiologists said these are going to
cause many deaths due to infections
grossly irresponsible
three weeks later there were much larger
rallies for black lives matter
and many of the same people including
many epidemiologists were either silent
or better said it's fine
don't worry about it now this might look
like irrationality
but it better reflects the fact that
people have multiple goals we have
social and moral goals
most of the experts at least in the
states have liberal politics and they
thought the black lives matter rallies
were just
and the trump rallies were not and this
is what dictated their response
similarly we shouldn't take people who
reject these experts
and necessarily say they're being stupid
maybe they just recognize that these
experts might have different priorities
on their own
finally i agree we're sometimes
irrational rule by our hearts and not
our heads
but we can also step back and deliberate
over how well we're doing
um and try to get better at it and this
is a tremendously powerful form of ira
of rationality and it's exactly what
we're going to do now
um okay great thanks for that paul
i mean yes patty what do you think do we
need to wise up and get more rational
about
our decisions what are your thoughts
thank you so much this is like exciting
questions because it is kind of worded
in a way
we should wise up and become more
rational
in order to live our life more
intelligently
and i think the question isn't posed
correctly i think we are rational and
emotional animals we are a mixture of
humans
determined by obviously our knowledge
what we know our attitudes
and also the emotional and spiritual
component of our beings is often
neglected
but it is very important when key
decisions are being made
and obviously the most glaring example
for someone in the from the uk
is the vote of brexit it was by no means
a rational
vote it was entirely an emotional vote
where people were projecting their ideas
their beliefs their values
their satisfaction dissatisfaction into
you know on a paper simple looking
question
but in reality the complexity of it
wasn't absolutely not rationally grasped
the rational evidence was absolutely
clear what's going to happen
opposed january 2021 it was an emotional
decision
so how do we take it from there i think
you need to better understand what we as
the humans
are how do we change our behavior taking
into consideration
the cognitive component the rational
knowledge part of our beings but also
the attitudes
and the emotions and i will just give
you an example um from one of our
research projects a few years ago
we developed a website informing public
about antibiotic resistance
one of the major global problems we all
should
rise up about and do something about
combating antibiotic
antimicrobial resistance and this
website was aimed at general public
and from the evaluations we were
assessing uh not just the behavior what
they would actually do when they
when people get ill just a knowledge and
attitudes towards antibiotics
and in our research we have discovered
that only 25
of the people who improve their
knowledge after using our
website as an intervention actually
change their attitudes towards
prescribing
the right way they would expect not to
be prescribed antibiotics for basic of
some calls basically
so the right relationship between
attitude and knowledge was only achieved
in 25 of people the rest of the people
sometimes improve their knowledge and
decrease their attitude first
prescribing
the wrong way i would expect even more
prescriptions even though they actually
answer logical questions correctly after
the intervention better
than before the intervention so
it clearly illustrates how emotions and
how
attitudes are linked to our knowledge
but not
directly not linearly and if you look at
the um
standard on behavior change theory using
the combi
so bringing together our um capabilities
to do some decisions such as skills or
knowledge
our opportunity we need to be an
opportunity to actually do something
such as take a vaccination but also the
motivation and i think the motivations
in the comedy
is i think the most important to answer
your questions what are our motivations
what drives us and how we change the
motivations of us as human beings or us
as a society
sort of trying to steer the decisions
towards
more rational and decisions towards our
personal
well-being and also our goal we're good
interesting
okay well wow thanks for that intro
patty to your position as well
dan it's uh it's your turn to tell us
whether or not we do need to wise up
and get more rational about our
decisions to continue watching this
video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's
decision apparatus so patty i i don't
know
you very well but paul i know for many
years and i love the guy
now that's an emotional thing i see him
and he smile
and we had an opportunity to talk we
haven't caught up for a while